all right guys welcome to Snowmass ski
resort today
we're going up there about 12 and a half
thousand feet above sea level and we're
gonna ski out of bounds and go camping
but there's uh one little problem I
haven't been skiing in 25 years
[Music]
all right we're gonna put on skis for
the first time in 25 years and uh these
are Tech bindings too so never used
those before we'll see what happens
all right
[Applause]
yep that happens
this is humbling in my mind I'm still 19
years old and tearing up black diamonds
I'm really rusty
[Applause]
that's coming back to me
oh I forgot how excruciatingly cold ski
lifts are
I've been planning all summer to do some
extreme high elevation camping and back
country skiing but you know I just don't
have a lot of experience camping over 10
000 feet and elevation sickness is a
real issue elevation sickness affects
different people differently sometimes
you get nausea and headaches and it's a
lot like carbon monoxide poisoning and
other people get loopy from the
elevation which can be really dangerous
if you're out by yourself and your
judgment gets impaired Snowmass Village
is at eight and a half thousand feet so
it's a great elevation to get acclimated
and the mountains up to 12 and a half
thousand feet so I can kind of see how
my body reacts without being miles from
health so I'm just gonna go ahead and
try to get familiar with my skis and
then I'm gonna go and scout out some
locations
all right guys we're at a little over 11
000 feet and it is gold my face hurts
didn't buy to get it off the ski lift
that was my big goal for the day
instead of having the traditional
downhill skis I've got trekking skis on
they're kind of a cross-country ski
Alpine Ski hybrid and these bindings are
called Tech bindings I can ski with my
heel clicked in like a downhill ski or I
can ski with my heel loose like a
cross-country ski this whole setup isn't
meant for groomed icy trails and Mogul
so I've got to take it easy otherwise
I'm going to pop out of my bindings or
break something but this is kind of a
nice way to get used to my gear before I
go into the backcountry oh my goodness
hit is so cold
[Music]
thank you
it's a lot of work
[Music]
ah
I'm feeling old and tired but it sure is
pretty
look at this
all right this is the other reason I
came to Snowmass this is the ski
boundary everything on this side of the
Rope is part of the ski resort
everything on this side of the Rope is
national forest and you can camp in
National Forest and Snowmass is one of
the few ski resorts that allows people
to ski in and out of boundaries
so now we just gotta find a good spot to
cross and to camp
foreign
there we go
now I've got cross-country skis
oh
and just like that I'm off in the
mountains all by myself this is amazing
yeah I think you can definitely find a
place to camp out here
welcome
all right so I got my backpack all
packed up got all my camping gear in
here now
a little trickier with all this weight
on my back all right guys I'm here with
the ski lift I'm gonna put the camera
down and try to get on this thing as
gracefully as we can with this backpack
well there we go that worked out really
well it's amazing how much easier life
is when you're not trying to film it on
to the next Cuba
I'm getting the hang of this
oh this is pretty and it's even more
pretty because I didn't have to walk
uphill
oh look at this I think this might be
where I need to set up camp now luckily
this snow is pretty hard packed so I am
just gonna pop out of my skis and start
shoveling
right now I'm at 11 and a half thousand
feet and anytime you get over 10 000
feet above sea level you have shortness
of breath it's harder to stay warm your
energy level just goes way down oh I'm
just taking it easy
shovel a little bit rested
[Applause]
foreign
I dug myself a nice little hole here
there's really two reasons I did this
one I was curious to see how deep the
snow was and two I want to see what the
different layers of snow are you see
here I finally hit dirt when I stand on
the dirt the natural snow lines about
here so we got about five feet ten
inches of snow but this cross section
also tells me how deep I should dig I
don't want to dig all the way down to
the ground because the ground might not
be even and level so I want to dig down
as deep as I can where I have a nice
compact layer of snow you can see the
snow here it's pretty hard and crunchy
supportive and then right about here
it's just like this granular Crystal
stuff if I dig down much deeper I'm
going to break through this layer of
supportive snow and I'm going to get
down into this mushy stuff so I don't
think I want to dig any deeper I'm just
going to go and level this out we're
gonna call that good
foreign
got the tent up the sun's just barely
disappearing over the mountains once
that sun goes down it is going to get
really cold I know it's supposed to be
negative five down at the base of the
mountain so I have no clue how cold it's
going to get up here at 11 and a half
thousand feet I forgot my coat and glove
over there go go gadget arm yay
mm-hmm
oh man that sun disappeared behind that
mountain so fast oh my goodness it is
getting cold so quick
well I got everything set up we still
got a little light so I might as well
start cooking some food while I can
still see things
you know if you're gonna go winter
camping in the mountains don't bring
propane or butane it'll freeze up on you
so easily so I've got white gas right
here which is basically unleaded fuel or
petrol now a lot of you know that if you
go out and touch steel and when it's icy
cold it just hurts your fingers brass is
so much worse I touch this little brass
nozzle oh my goodness I thought my skin
came off
now that's cooking
all right let's get
snow melted
to take out the water's boiling at 195
degrees now normally water boils at 212
degrees Fahrenheit because we're so high
above sea level the air pressure is
lower and the water boils at a lower
temperature a little physics there for
you
I don't want my food to cool down so I'm
Gonna Keep It In Here
all right
my finger just froze to my spoon
we're gonna try some beef stew
oh that tastes amazing I gotta eat
quickly before this stew gets cold
all right that's it this is how you do
the dishes when it's cold out
all right that's good
got some orange zest herbal tea I gotta
tell you it smells like the best thing
in the world right now
oh my goodness
oh that was the best thing I've ever
drank I brought a couple more of those
tea bags I think I'm gonna use them up
I just spilled boiling water on my hands
and it didn't hurt that's how cold I am
I'm gonna go put this hot water in my
sleeping bag get it warmed up
I got little drops of beef stew on my
jacket luckily it's frozen so I can just
brush it off you know Silver Lining on
everything
I brought these down booties to wear in
the tent and they will be warm but right
now they're freezing
oh
got my down booties and my puppy pants
on let's get into let's get into 10 here
gotta pull out all my night filming
equipment here
all right we got these adhesive body
warmers we're gonna bust some of these
out stick them on my undershirt
oh my toes are so numb right now I've
got my hot water bottle down the bottom
of my bag if I can barely feel it but
what I can feel feels good
guys it is no joke cold right now it
says it's negative 17 on this mountain
right now this is gonna be a no joke
freezing camp out well it's only about
six o'clock not quite my bedtime yet so
I'm gonna put on some audio books and
eat some licorice I would call that a
good time is how I party
hello that's so Frozen
all right guys
well guys it's about 10 o'clock and my
cell phone says it's negative 24 degrees
outside it is so cold this tent is just
caked in ice all the moisture from my
breath is immediately hitting the walls
of the tent and turning into crystals
hung my glasses at the top of the tent
and look how much Frost is gathered up
on it but other than the fact my pillow
keeps leaking
everything's holding up pretty well it's
pretty late so I think I'm going to turn
this off I'll give you guys updates in
the morning
good morning oh it was so cold last
night
I took a screenshot of the temperature
around midnight it was negative 26 but
the sun's come up and now it's a balmy
negative 23.
the inside of my tent is so covered in
Frost those look like they take my skin
off if I tried to put them on look at
all this Frost oh it's thick
about the worst was I kept having to get
up to use the bathroom last night and
when I'd sit up and I'd touch the walls
of the tent at all it would just dump
this Frost snow on me get in my bag and
get in my face and everything and but
other than that uh I'm doing okay it was
a rough night's sleep because it is
legit cold and this is a little bit more
than my gear can handle I had to stay in
one position if you roll around too much
you get colder bits and pieces of me
would be really cold oh then they'd be
warm like I woke up with my ankles just
really cold but my feet hot one hip
would be cold and the other one would be
warm or it wasn't bad or was it freezing
but it was just enough where it was a
hard to sleep oh but I can tell it is
brutally cold and I don't want to get
out of my bag I might just stay here for
just a little bit longer
foreign
oh my goodness
oh my hands my fingers are so Frozen I
can only have my hands out of the gloves
for about four minutes before they're
just toasted
matches just don't work well at this
temperature
foreign
custom biscuits and gravy but it's still
a little bit Crunchy just can't cook it
well enough at this temperature
here's what it is it's food and it's
moderately warm
all right gotta start putting things
away before my hands freeze
this is probably the warmest backpacking
mat I've ever had exped makes it it's
the dura 8r it's pretty bulky for a
backpacking mat but for winter camping
it's awesome this is the uh extra long
and extra wide model
foreign
[Music]
I've got to put numb toes in cold boots
oh that is icy cold
what an adventure this has to be one of
the most gorgeous campsites I've ever
slept at
and look we got the sun coming up oh it
feels like it's a balmy negative 18. as
much fun as this been I gotta get going
I got a long way to go
[Applause]
all right
back on the skier door
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I thought that was frostbite turns out
it's just lint from my dark blue stuff
see it comes right off
laughs
well this definitely was an interesting
campout I was expecting the altitude to
be a big deal turns out it wasn't I was
thinking it was going to be negative
five turns out it was negative 26. but
you know I kept War but I managed to
have a good time and hopefully you guys
enjoyed watching if you want to see more
camping Adventure videos from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel make sure
to click subscribe put on new videos
every Saturday morning I'll see you next
Saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching